et la chef de la diplomatie française
Catherine Colonna a annoncé des sommes
très très importantes regardez
je voulais vous dire que l'aide que
collectivement nous avons
annoncé aujourd'hui les uns et les
autres atteints au même dépassent les
800 millions d'euros dont parlait le
président de
en fait je suis heureuse de pouvoir vous
annoncer que nous dépassons ce chiffre
et que nous sommes plus proches du
milliard d'euros
et donc la France va remettre la main à
la poche c'est ça 76 millions ils vont
rajouter au 200 millions qu'ils avaient
déjà décaissés ça fait combien donc ça
fait 1 milliard à peu près en total oui
d'accord pas que la France mais au total
des dons alors moi je trouve ça
formidable je pense combien ça fait à
peu près c'est alors 76 décaissez-la il
y avait déjà 200 on est à 276 selon mes
chiffres pour la France encore une fois
moi je trouve ça formidable qu'on a de
l'Ukraine parce que c'est vrai que la
Russie attaque les infrastructures
civiles donc ils ont froid ils ont faim
etc très bien mais quand on voit notre
sujet d'hier à propos de nos
établissements scolaires et d'autres
d'autres qui nous ont contacté depuis il
y a aussi des priorités en France donc
si on peut aider l'Ukraine il faut qu'on
aide nos lycéens collégiens élèves de
primaires qui ont froid qui n'ont pas
des établissements digne 2 si l'argent
est là il doit pouvoir aider aussi les
enfants français voilà ce que je dis
vraiment à 6 problème c'était que les
lycées j'aurais été content moi moi
j'aurais été j'aurais dit bravo si c'est
que l'initiés mais il y a pas que les
lycées c'est tous c'est beaucoup de
Français qu'il faut aider et tu as
beaucoup de Français alors allez-y
démago si vous voulez il y a pas de
problème mais
expliquer aux gens qu'on a donné un
milliard on veut bien aider l'Ukraine il
y a pas de problème on aide l'Ukraine
200 millions je vais me dire l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre mais sauf que
l'autre on l'a pas l'autre on l'a pas on
est de l'Ukraine et là on est en train
de nous dire qu'on va nous couper le
courant on est en train de me dire qu'il
y a des boulangers qui vont crever de
faim on est en train de nous dire que la
France elle va pas bien le passe Navigo
l'augmente tout augmente on voit bien
quand on fait les courses de 100 balles
tu ressors avec 3 sacs moi je veux bien
aider l'Ukraine j'ai dit ça coûte de
l'argent des des lucrètes et on voit on
voit encore alors après un empêche pas
l'autre moi je veux bien des lunettes
mais je vais vous dire moi aujourd'hui
j'ai pour l'instant je pense que j'ai
les moyens d'aider l'Ukraine nous on a
autour de la table tous les moyens
d'aider l'Ukraine mais il y a des gens
qui nous regardent il y a des gens dans
le public ils ont pas les moyens d'aider
l'Ukraine et ça faut qu'ils se rendre
dans le crâne le gouvernement mais là
j'ai pas tout le monde on Ukraine c'est
pas de l'argent qu'on a enlevé aux
Français
il y a encore des gens qui dorment
dehors qui ont su pas de quoi s'habiller
de se nourrir je comprends que ce soit
que ça paraît que ça paraisse écoeurant
et c'est vrai qu'il faut aider l'Ukraine
pour des raisons mais les gens qui sont
dans la merde il y a un petit qui sont
contrecarres non mais si c'est ça le
problème alors on va dire qu'il y a des
magot mais il a parfaitement raison
c'est comme les crèches rappelle-toi il
fallait des places de crèches et tu as
des Français qui qui n'arrivent même pas
à avoir une place pour leur enfant et on
leur dit ben on va prendre les infos
Ukrainiens même si il faut les aider
c'est pour les Français c'est inaudible
malheureusement c'est comme ça alors
c'est injuste sachant rien mais quand on
trouve 250 millions comme ça on peut
trouver dans 50 millions pour que les
gens dans plus dehors alors c'est démago
de le dire mais c'est la vérité
depuis que tu es Juifs tu te fais
beaucoup rire
et avec ce que dit Benjamin c'est
beaucoup plus facile de dire ça
audible pour le public pour les
téléspectateurs de dire ça mais on a un
problème nous la France c'est qu'on est
membre permanent à l'ONU donc à ce titre
là internationalement on a un rôle et on
a un pouvoir alors on peut dire nous ici
tous finalement on n'en veut plus de
cette place parce que effectivement nous
on a l'herbe l'arme nucléaire et on en a
rien à [ __ ] et en fait on est on est
plus sur le on est plus sur la scène
politique mondiale et en fait on va plus
on va plus dire ce qu'il faut faire et
ce qu'il faut pas faire le Portugal on
les emmerde pas l'Espagne on les emmerde
pas l'Italie contre le Maroc le problème
c'est que nous on est ce qui n'a rien à
voir on est membre permanent et donc on
a un vrai rôle international alors si on
veut plus jouer ce rôle là parce que
c'est aussi
mais je ne veux pas qu'il y ait des gens
qui souffrent et qui payent de ça je ne
veux pas qu'on dise à des gens que faut
chauffer à 18 de marbonner 19 on va vous
couper les si on n'est pas l'Ukraine et
si la Russie race l'Ukraine est-ce que
tu penses nous moi
le pouvoir d'achat les problèmes
d'énergie est-ce que tu penses qu'on va
dire après réellement
c'est juste une question de logique
c'est quand tu donnes de l'argent à un
autre pays bah en fait vraiment il est
en train de se dire bah ouais mais nous
il y a des gens qui galèrent énormément
de donner les armes à l'Ukraine parce
que ça fait des emplois aussi pour nous
et à ce moment-là à ce moment-là on dit
ben non nous ça nous intéresse plus on
fait plus d'armes on donne plus d'argent
mais Géraldine je dis juste ça va durer
combien de temps
moi je veux bien je suis comme on dit
ici nous on n'est pas très impacté si ça
dure 5 ans les gens c'est vrai qu'ils
vont crevettes 5 ans comme ça 5 ans il
faut aller faire des courses juste
déconner aller faire des courses
tu as raison mais je le redis je le
redis c'est pas audible de savoir qu'on
distribue de l'argent aussi facilement
qu'on trouve surtout de sombrer comme
qu'on trouve comme ça alors que les gens
qui n'ont pas à manger et surtout ils
ont qui dorment dehors et je redis
Macron avait dit en 2017
elle dit nous avons on a une place à
l'ONU excusez-moi Géraldine c'est l'ONU
avait réglé un conflit comme celui-là ça
serait donc ce que vous dites là au nom
de l'ONU et de notre place dans le monde
arrêtons de donner à l'Ukraine ça c'est
absolument pas Audi par les temps qui
courent sur préoccupons-nous ce qui se
passe sur notre territoire à un moment
ça va moi j'étais totalement pour qu'on
donne et à un moment il faut arrêter non
mais à un moment il faut faire attention
vous avez un avis euh ben moi je sais
pas faudrait peut-être demander au
Qatar je suis arrivé à soudoyer tout le
Parlement européen avec
un coup de de centaines de millions
voire même de de milliards pour pouvoir
demanderai pas un coup de main et
rapport avec le sujet et ben le le fait
d'avoir du pognon elle a envie de dire
exactement si on avait du pneu
facilement on le donnerai Castaldi voilà
je te le dis pour l'instant on l'a pas